when it comes to exploring sprawling
fantasy worlds urban dystopias all the
ruins of a post apocalypse I'd prefer to
go it alone to be the hero among a sea
of NPCs the chosen one the savior
everyone's been waiting for that kind of
thing
there's just something that undercuts
the glory of quest completion when
you're surrounded by randoms in an
online game incessantly bunny hopping
and tea bagging
luckily death stranding isn't that kind
of multiplayer game though it does blend
the experience of a single-player game
with online multiplayer elements instead
of running around with other players it
leans more on significant social
elements with an unseen community of
porters that is other players who share
your world living structures and signs
in their wake the first week I played
death stranding was when the service
happened to be offline my roots were
quiet and the only signs of life with
the NPCs that requested and received my
orders when the service came online
alongside the game's release my pristine
hillsides were littered with signs
structures and all kinds of evidence
that other people had tramped through my
game world this was to be expected when
the service came online but what did
surprise me was my realization that
death strandings multiplayer elements
made the game way way better much like
me Sam also prefers to go it alone and
the meditative moments while you're
walking alone through death surroundings
wide open spaces present the game's most
emotional highs
[Music]
so why not just keep the experience
between me and Loeb roars dulcet folk
tunes well given its themes of
rebuilding society and human connection
it wouldn't make a lot of sense for
deaths training to be strictly
single-player on top of that multiplayer
elements are integrated in such a way
that they don't impede on either the
overarching narrative message all the
moments of serene isolation in the
minute-to-minute experience the specific
ways that you and other players impact
the game world ensure that it's always
about helping your fellow Porter player
made signs a little nudges of support or
useful warnings fabricated structures
can be lifesavers and likes received
enhance the game long sentiment that you
are appreciated and that your creations
no matter how small actually matter
finding a structure after long arduous
stretches of walking is like finding an
oasis in the desert not simply because
you happen to need it but because it's a
sign of reassurance that other people
have walked the long and demanding paths
you have even if they go unseen
particularly as the game creates beaten
paths once enough people use the same
route death stranding incorporates
multiplayer elements in much the same
way as journey in that you can engage
and disengage as much as you'd like
engaging isn't necessary for
experiencing the story but it really
does make the overall experience better
you can choose to engage with others in
your world by showering them with likes
or keep them on the periphery and the
limits on the multiplayer experience
which amounts only to a few dozen signs
structures and optional strand contracts
maintain the tonal integrity of the core
experience
Sam's general disinterest in people
which evolves through the story is a
nice parallel to those who grow to enjoy
the social elements of the game in some
circumstances it can be exceedingly
lonely seeing notifications of other
porters using your structures and
sending you likes but never getting to
see any of them in the flesh and that's
what makes the system work on multiple
levels
there's nothing irritating about getting
notifications that dropped cargo has
been delivered that you've received a
like on a long abandoned ladder all that
another player has contributed to a road
you built instead of a bustling port a
riddled countryside what you get are
things like holographic cans showing
where other players have rested and if
you so choose
the opportunity to play supply requests
all fulfill some yourself
it's the limits of player engagement
that make the multiplayer and social
elements in deaths trending so appealing
there is a pervading sense that other
players are there to help and cheer you
on and that support is available to you
even if you would rather play your games
alone